hang on a second there gang before we
get the show started the keep it moving
2021 tour
is in full swing as you know yeah we
have some additions
sure we have some announcements kippy
straighten them out
guys we're coming to providence rhode
island august 11th
uh we're going to be in boston
massachusetts august 12th shaolin new
brunswick new jersey
august 25th jersey stress factory we're
going to be
in timonium maryland outside baltimore
at magooby
uh-oh on august 26th then the big thing
moon tower comedy [ __ ] out we're gonna
be there
at the fest at the fest couple of festy
boys
uh that's gonna be at the end of
september on september 23rd 24th 25th
it's gonna be bonkos get some tickies
it's gonna be a good time
can't wait to see you there welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they grow up to be
classy
or just a big old piece of trash i'm
your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's feeling good
feeling fine yeah keeping an eye on her
she sleeps a lot
yeah you know what i mean i don't know
what it is i think it's the percocet
could be the percocet
you got to watch out my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he's
the
ceo of ru garbage he's really an
international businessman
kind of the head bozo around here kind
of my boss so do me a favor make me look
good show them a little respect
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here as always thanks for
tuning in please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are
true the roof cooking baby and then
patreon.com
goddamn lots i mean that's the real
[ __ ] that's the real moneymaker
love that money a lot of money talk
about new money uh patreon.com you get a
bunch of bonus content the whole nine
yards and also t-bone yelling at me
check out are you garbage on instagram
we're almost at ten thousand we need
that [ __ ] swipe up yeah need that
swipe up move some ticky wikis
and how about a nice shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good he was the pride
of the chicago comedy scene
now new york city comedian he's out
there in queens keeping everybody in
line
tebow and mcmuffin it's toby mcmullen
everybody come on what's up dudes what's
up t-bone nothing get a lot of love from
chicago watching you boys lunch it with
the malort
shots yeah that's that [ __ ] stunk dude
you look like tweens drinking vodka for
the first time
oh man like my first newport gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests
back back with us today third time on
the show
if you haven't seen his uh first episode
you got to go check it out if you
haven't seen his last episode you got to
go check it out
uh we are super pumped to have him back
of course you know him from we might be
drunk tuesdays with stories
and the smash hit special out to lunch
i've heard about it ladies and gentlemen
he's a good-looking kid
tight little body about to go off the
market
we love him you love him give it up for
the one the only
mr mark norman yeah look at ya look at
him
thank you thank you good to be back in
uh the basement
it smells like cigarettes oh that's
that's right
[Laughter]
it's our potpourri special what is that
marlborough
it's a combo that's a combination all
right more of a parliament family to be
honest
i got you uh buddy first off
congratulations oh
thanks yeah congratulations on the
engagement i'm a lucky guy he's a good
looking man
it's getting married to anderson cooper
that guy's got a tight body
oh man nice place downtown oh yeah nice
salt and pepper that kid silver fox yeah
uh we got you a little present we did
we're trying to we're trying to you know
we're a little new money over here you
know what i mean we're happy for you
we thought we'd get you something that
you might enjoy i'm nervous and uh
behalf of the the are you garbage squad
and antoine corporate cody of course
wow this is beautiful i know you're i
know you're a whiskey guy
yeah well i just quit
we only took a couple of sips out of it
too yeah
don't put it in the freezer it might
freeze i'm gonna drink this on the pot
on the we might be drunk
there you go oh yeah that'll look like a
cool guy it's really it's my favorite uh
it's my favorite whiskey
it's really never heard ryder's tears
yeah it's a it's a
it's a little seeker a little little
hidden gem did i hear correctly that you
guys are gonna
make your own that's true you got it
fatty i mean we're going
uh we're making so much funny when he
calls you fatty yeah
yeah he says it perfectly i save it for
non-fest
but uh you you fluctuate like oprah over
there
but uh yeah i uh
[Laughter]
yeah we we we're making our own rye so
uh that's crazy
we're just shooting for it i love it we
know a guy in the business and we said
why the hell not he said let's try it
scotty pippins is failing drake's is
failing i feel like you guys are on the
road every weekend you're basically
doing a campaign
yeah every club in the city so uh let's
do it dude it's like avion [ __ ]
vinnie chase [ __ ] that's
awesome yeah yeah exactly the next
george clooney that could make you
millionaires well it could it's a shot
it might make us nothing hopefully we
break even but we'll give it a whirl
mark cuban buys you out that's it right
there
picture you two on shark tank
both hammered drunk showing up
making a move on the blonde tenant lady
oh yeah shout out to barbara
i call damon the n-word and that's why
i'm out
i like your older stuff better oh yeah
now gang this is a uh this is a company
episode we're gonna be answering some
patreon questions here
uh but before we get to that we wanted
to kind of continue a little bit
now that you're taking this step into
adulthood it's a big jump
yeah scary jump we wanted we wanted to
talk to you a little bit that follow-up
with some questions about that stuff
um you know you're a wacky crazy guy
but you know
[Laughter]
but when you pull that away i mean
you're extremely organized extremely
hard working you are an adult you own
your own place
sure where do you feel that you're at as
far as like like
are you you have your [ __ ] pretty much
together you feel like an adult
um of course you never do i have this
the penis of a child
but you know obviously i'd love to
drink every night and and you gotta get
it together i wouldn't mind having a
little little norman
uh yeah that'd be cute you know a little
ding-a-ling flipping around the had the
residence there and
running around doing material yeah
what's the deal with formula it's got a
little moped
yeah exactly so that'd be fun and all
that so
i figured hey you gotta work hard and
play hard and that's really what life's
all about is that balance
like we all want to just eat
chimichangas and uh
do crank but if you go all one way
you're not
if you do the hard work and then you
earn the fun i feel like it means more
yeah it's way yeah yeah
for sure the payoff is way better right
right so that's what it's all about and
where am i going i'm not going anywhere
so yeah i'll tie the knot
and you guys live together now yes and
will you do so she lives
with with you at your place yeah and
that you guys will stay there
yeah i mean i'd hope to go bigger one
day uh i mean she's gotten much bigger
so we have to no i'm joking but i hope
they get a bigger place
has it become more of a couple's
apartment than it was when you were
there by yourself
you guys moved no you guys moved
together oh yeah
yeah you're not yeah he's not in uh we
were in a shoebox a little pandemic and
it was we were button heads
you own that place though i do i sold it
i rented it i rented out to an old asian
lady she's the best tenant of all time
she sits in there and knits and uh does
tai chi
all night she's quiet the windows are
broken the locks don't work there's
roaches and she doesn't notice
that's great i think she's on opium or
something but
her and tony hinchcliffe are doing a
podcast
i can't wait to hear that yeah wait so
did you buy a new place or are you guys
right i'm renting this one but i hate
renting i feel like the city's got a
hold on me that's what new york is it's
a video game
you show up and you're on the most
difficult level and you get your ass
kicked and
you get a place and you you live in
bushwick then you live in crown heights
then you get to maybe
williamsburg get closer and closer and
closer
and the less and less roommates i
remember the first time i got my own
place
no co-signer i was like i literally felt
like like i
got elected president yes the greatest
my crowning achievement
exactly then you get a hot pod and then
a better studio
it just keeps it's incremental and
that's what life's all about is pushing
that boulder up the goddamn hill what's
his name syphilis
yeah so yeah that's what it's all about
gonorrhea
you lose in l.a or austin or whatever
it's too comfortable and i need to keep
pushing that's the only way i can stay
sane and
feel alive and relevant you need the gun
to your head to keep
[ __ ] pushing and like yeah
it's funny because we're you know we're
you know the pods this pod's starting to
[ __ ] pick up and cook and like we're
financially stable from where you
were as like a [ __ ] road feature or
like you know running around
new york doing bars sure bar shows been
there and now i'm like
i'm like oh great i can finally let my
foot off the gas and relax a little bit
but then i go oh no no i'm not
i don't like that that feeling of
comfort i need
let's leave let's do more [ __ ]
patreon yeah let's [ __ ] book more
shows on the road
right yeah and i think we're in the same
boat where i feel like for a guy
hair loss is our biological clock yes
you know like you're hanging in there
you got a beautiful head of hair
charlie's got by the way
you got a lot of hair and a lot of
cholesterol but you do
t-bone look that's a mane and a half i
mean that's like samson over there
but uh people's got a piece on him too
bulge
dude yeah he's uncircumcised as you can
tell he was checking the mics i almost
started talking into his crotch
hey you guys using a boom mic quite a
huh it's a long board
but yeah
it's hanging over the hair is going and
i'm on the propetion
i feel like i got to get married get
some wedding pics have a kid get some tv
spots uh with this this hair and then
then
i felt the same thing it was like
because like obviously i call him fat he
calls me ball that's the question
you think yours is going it's going
you're thin in a bit but you're fine
i got five years left but uh five weeks
yeah the irish go it goes but it's also
like i just got married to a hot hot
lady
i'm happy about that i'm pretty
successful you know we're getting
successful i'll go i'm not gonna i don't
need i'm not gonna be a leading man good
looking bird
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got it i got
a nice lady way out of his league
oh she's foreign she's foreign she paid
for the studio
wow foreign anything but german is
really high so
that's what she is i know i'm joking
i'm sure he's fact checking everything
over here jesus christ
put the dictionary away
that would have been a hell of a gamble
what a pull
so you i mean dude you so you own a
property in new york city that you're
renting at you're a [ __ ] landlord
basically you're an adult it's a
headache i need an assistant i'm in
way over my head here but take it one
day at a time
assistant really i would like one really
i mean i just can't keep up i miss
flights and i
i come the wrong day i mean i had to
reschedule with you 16 times i just uh
i'm all over the road and then my
parents show up and i'm a mess
oh i gotta get it together that's what
i'm talking about they're cheap
for like 15 bucks an hour really yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i got to do it what do you do
anything t-bone you're busy
oh my you don't want me in his ass i
don't want that hog
all over the spreadsheets your girl's
going to be taking a peek at that thing
i'll be like norman the rent's late but
she's she's good for it she's a good
lady
oh jeez uh yeah you don't want t-bone in
charge of your affairs yeah
we got it we got an intern you could
have oh yeah we got an intern the bud
light intern shout out
bud light intern it's not going anywhere
all right keep my eye on him
um so you got you got you kind of backed
your way into an investment property a
little bit
yes you know what i mean you have you
know you have the opportunity to do how
are you setting up are you do you have
like a 401k
are you doing any any retirement stuff
or do you have something to do
like i do i'm a money guy yeah yeah so
he's doing all that and you you lose a
lot it's scary to be using we're gonna
need 20 grand for this just to open it
that just gave me chills
40 grand that's what i made last year
i'm talking about a couple of savings
bonds yeah a couple of t-bags
are small exactly so it's all scary but
it's all a dulty and i just kind of
closed my
eyes and looked at my fingers and and
i'll look at it in 50 years and
hopefully
hopefully it's there yeah yeah yeah
there we go that you get you gave me a
good idea so we know
agent manager business manager yep you
got a lawyer too
no i i know a guy who's a lawyer and i
i'll call him
booney's guy everybody uses the guys
there's one of the guys from gooney
oh chunk i don't it is chunk from
goonies is a
entertainment lawyer right he does the
the the shuffle
i remember that yeah he's good i think
but people use him
a lot of people do like everybody uh you
have an accountant because i think i use
the same guy as you
altman yeah yeah yeah we all share a
therapist we share an account no
yeah it's bad we share a butt plug it's
a it's a messy community we're in here
yeah it's funny to talk to that guy
because he's so ingrained in comedy he's
like the patreon's cooking i'm like
that's so crazy it's like talking to a
comic i know i'm like you know more than
my dad
about my life that's awesome yeah he's
coming to my netflix like he's an animal
he likes comments he's like
he's a comedy fan yeah yeah that's
awesome well that's pretty good
that's pretty it's pretty sharp that's
pretty adult credit cards you have
multiple credit cards
i got a bunch and i don't use them and
altman yells at me he's like gotta build
credit you got no credit
we do this with everybody with with
every good do you know your credit limit
i don't i don't
i don't know anything i can barely add
anything with numbers i'm out
i'm a word guy you don't know what how
much you can put on each credit card no
idea
really no i mean we can swipe it right
now and figure it out i don't know i
don't know how that works that's
actually the next question
yeah we get the credit card machine this
kid's wide open he don't know what he's
doing
i don't we got a whale here oh yeah i'm
a mess
uh do you have an amex card i wish
because i want to get in that lounge
that's big one day i'll get in that
lounge who do you what uh what
what airline do you take points do you
have delta delta big delta guy
delta's going to get the call to various
shabby yeah are you first class for the
most part
i get bumped up quite a bit cause i've
got so many miles will you buy first
class or no
no no god what are you crazy come on so
you won't buy your if they if somebody's
sending you somewhere
yes of course of course you're not
laying out yourself
i'll never buy myself anything nice
louie gave us all rolexes for the tour
i would never i just keep it in a closet
and i keep
clothes on like winter coats on top of
it i've never looked at it never
really i don't know what time that
thing's got on it i just
what am i gonna wear that around yeah
why don't you wear it ah can't we
it's very it is out of a character for
him yeah i don't know i mean you can't
be jumping the turn style wearing a
[ __ ] rollout
people i mean that's a good you can't be
jumping the turn style
no there are cops are gone oh my god he
still steals a lot too big
thief i want to be getting tased at a
7-eleven on tmz
hey that's a good credit
that would be a viral video baby [ __ ]
hour on netflix yeah
two seconds later two tvs on the phone
you saw your new clip exactly you want
to do a prank show
or whatever but yeah so uh yeah
big airport thief that's crazy i won't
steal from you or your grandma
or or your house party yeah well she
won't notice she's uh senile
but yeah i'll steal from a hudson news
all day long
and you rack that [ __ ] up i get a
hard-boiled egg i got a cliff bar
i get a bottle of water and uh like a
reese's pieces
that's eighteen dollars yeah yeah and
like for some reason i don't know what
kind of oxygen they're pumping in the
gas
or the airport but i forget i'm like oh
whatever i'll just pay nine dollars for
that
yeah you just [ __ ] fleeced me you
have you have this old school
you get this from your parents right
well they don't steal no that's
be weird if they were in the supermarket
with a [ __ ] ham under
underneath everybody be cool yeah
nobody be a hero right right um
you don't you don't buy things in
yourself there's no splurge nah
like i'll when i was a single guy i
would go out with these girls and just
lavish restaurants and drink cocktail
18.
whatever you want because it wasn't for
me yeah it's for me it's like
you can't do it water and crackers yeah
yeah you can't wear
you can wear rolex i look at this i got
a time max this is made for a [ __ ]
kid look at this thing
this is like a special needs boy i did
catch it i noticed that
the other day or when you got in oh yeah
this is what like your grandma wears
yeah
but it was cheap and it works and it you
know keeps ticking i think you should
wear the rolex i can't do that what is
that that's nice
this is a citizen that's a movement that
is a movement watch ladies and gentlemen
mvmt movement watch
stamps.com if you want one
what about for your what up for your
fiance i got a huge ring because it's
hers
so i can do that yeah but if it's for me
it ain't happening you laid it out you
you couple of bucks yeah
yeah that number oh boy whatever you're
thinking
go up really yeah that's crazy they get
i mean they say what is it a quarter
or three month salary right so they yeah
well there's two
oh maybe it is two two t-bone can you
pull that rule up yeah yeah pull it i
think it's
it's one or two i think it's yeah so
it's like glation it might be three
[ __ ] nuts but who knows everybody's
got a different salary that's why
it's a shitty little uh standard thing
we do here
you know if you're a mcdonald's guy and
then if you're uh
elon musk yeah at least two months
salary on the engagement ring
two month salary nice i did that but i
was making about 14 grand a year so
[ __ ] really worked in my favor that's
good three spots at the pair
they passed the bucket around i made
eight but that's the other thing you
give the ring and she goes
we got to play in the engagement party
we got to think about whether i'm like
oh i thought it was done
no you buddy you just got started are
you guys going to swing this yourself
yeah well we'll have some parental help
monetarily but we're going to go to new
orleans do it up
where she's fun she's a great gal and
she's not insane where she's like we're
doing the
rainbow room on the empire state shore
700 people
four different costume changes no no
yeah she's just gonna we're gonna
rent a big house party liquor band
that's because it's about the free yeah
it's about that i don't yeah all the
other
[ __ ] i find these people who go big with
the [ __ ] white horse coming out
and they're all pageantry and
flamethrowers they're getting a divorce
in a week
yeah it's just so weird imagine like i
remember it's like why would you be on a
horse that day like you're not doing
that every all the other time
like why goes so big because one day it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense i always
hated the uh
the bridal party's introductions to the
to the reception dances
when they come in [ __ ] dancing some
[ __ ] jerk off a football throw or
yeah
jerk off thinks he's still in shape from
college tries to do a split
[ __ ] like blows out his acl yeah yeah
i mean falls into somebody's aunt
yeah knocks over the chocolate fountain
how about the oh sorry
no that was it how about this he got
distracted a chocolate factory i ran out
i ran out of shitty tags i wasn't bad
the chocolate fountain i stepped on that
was good but the uh how about the
the weird uncle or a brother-in-law who
gave who gives the awkward speech
oh man those are getting big on
instagram oh really and i can't
the anxiety of watching somebody fumble
through a [ __ ] best man speech is the
worst
i got a bulletproof one guy he gave it
to me it's really good i've given it to
several people if you're
if your boy needs to get straightened
out have him get in touch with me wait
you're not gonna tell me to get up on
here
i guess we could do this i don't want to
i've given it i've given it to my
friends
yeah who are then like that's a perfect
way to wrap it up to wrap up a toast
okay
here's the here's the here's the rules
on it all right first rule
is you make sure as the best man you
make sure you're go you go last
don't let it don't let the maid of honor
[ __ ] show you up yeah all right yeah
here here everybody do that you make
sure you go last
you keep it three four minutes tops
sure number the second rule don't
[ __ ] cry nobody wants to see that
are dudes crying though like i wouldn't
cry at my brother's
wedding just saying insane just in case
that's crazy if you're quit [ __ ]
crying but you know what some people cry
because they got no closer
so they gotta go big it's a hack
that's a hack give it a hack move it's
props
you bust out the guitar for yeah they
got shot ah
you got me right right um
that one say something nice about her
family something nice about about your
family
something nice about the couple maybe a
little bit of humor but don't make fun
of anybody
keep it real classy really the zing is
always now
does it come out what is this caddyshack
what are we doing here
especially especially if the person's a
comic you know what i mean stay away
from it
do it do it nice then you close it out
all right so you close it out you want
me to do it i'll do it
i mean it seems like you're already
doing it i don't know why you're looking
at me
what do you want me to give you a
[ __ ] applause to start
you would say say guys raise the toast
just a toast and you say to the bride
and groom you say um
uh uh here's to the beginning the middle
and all things never here's the
beginning to the middle and all things
never ending
oh classy may everything that you want
in life wait for you quietly on your
doorstep and the love that you feel for
one another i pray that it'll last you a
lifetime
boom just like that what what fortune
cookie did you get that on yeah
yeah it was way better how i remembered
it before this i know i was on the spot
i [ __ ] it up wow that was a hallmark
i'm telling you it works out with that
it'll bring the [ __ ] house down how
did you memorize that i'll get you a
hand job i wrote it
you wrote that i wrote it for my
brother's wedding well
comedy's out you're going all in
that was beautiful i got misty i'm
telling you i'm dude i was [ __ ]
yacked out of my mind [ __ ]
i was he's saying three minutes the
speech was 45 minutes
he's gonna start a business with
everybody at the wedding
i got to start a bar let's go camping in
the morning huh
gang this podcast is brought to you by
our good friends at better help
uh mental health is uh you know is a
serious thing
you want to make sure that you're taking
care of yourself with taking care of
yourself physically yeah taking care of
yourself mentally and the folks at
better health are absolutely fantastic
uh what they do is they assess your
needs and within 48 hours you're talking
to a licensed
private therapist yeah it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online
same as traditional but it's all online
you know and i don't know
i you know for me i i really saw growth
i really saw a lot of help when i
started going to see somebody and talk
to somebody a few years ago it was
fantastic
and but this what they do is you don't
have to sit in a waiting room anymore in
the waiting room you can hear the other
guy talking you hear the other patients
talking
and i'm worried i'm going do they hear
me do i you know what's going on they
hear me crying like an idiot that guy's
into some weird [ __ ]
you know what i mean so but with uh with
better help
all that's removed because it's online
it's fantastic you can log into your
account at any time anywhere send a
message to your council
sure you'll get a timely thoughtful
response plus your schedule weekly
uh video or phone sessions and you won't
like i said ever have to sit in the
waiting room like a bozo wait till you
know what i mean
uh better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
to make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
find you know maybe someone else you
like better you can go to them it's easy
peasy
betterhelp once just wants you to start
living a happier life today you can
visit their website
see all the testimonials from all the
other people that have used it um
visit betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p
and join over one million people who
have taken the change
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they're now
adding additional recruiter they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states nice
i ain't talking two three states i'm
talking all 50 stretching out growing a
little bit
i mean there's a demand for it it's a
good stuff uh special offer for all you
garbage listeners you get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time betterhelp.com
garbage kip let's talk about our good
friends over there manscaped
yep love them you got a ball bag gotta
take care of it you gotta
take care of it i know a lot of people
might be a little nervous about that you
know i don't want to start then
start doing it man trim up the bushes
sure appreciate
or hey let me tell you something with
the new lawnmower 4.0
it couldn't be easier quieter safer
fantastic yeah guys uh and join over two
million men worldwide who have trusted
manscape with this exclusive offer two
million
twenty percent off and freezing for a
platinum album
free world that's two platinum albums
two platinum albums even better
20 off and free worldwide shipping with
promo code garbage at manscaped.com the
link will be in the description
uh gotta do it it's fantastic when i
started doing i'm taking it on the road
i do it in a hotel there's no
there's no mess you know what i mean i
get in the shower yeah have the shower
on because you could use it while it's
wet
yeah it's got the light i got the mirror
you can see
quiet yep ceramic no no no scrapes no
cuts no nothing
right there i cut the lawn let it fall
down to the drain pick it up throw it
out bada-boom bada-bing lather up i'm
out
i sometimes freshen clean sometimes i
turn it on and put it on my nightstand
just it's like it's like white nose
and i'm [ __ ] out baby it does
actually have it nice it doesn't have a
nice hump
nice little rumble to it yeah um now
it's time to get your own ball and
your ball hair and body trimmer with
manscape uh to make the me time the best
time
enhance your confidence with some nice
smooth boys down there
good times smooth as eggs uh you get 20
off of free shipping with promo code
garbage manscape.com
astrid's eggs one more time that's 20
off
and free shipping at manscape.com promo
code garbage
um i'm one of the first people to try
the new 4.0 they send them to us they're
fantastic
blown away by the performance uh the
craftsmanship detail 4.0
go check it out grab one man honestly
they're fantastic yeah i was the dirt
ball of the family
300 people walked out there hit that
murdered brought that outs down
and from that point on i was like if any
of my friends [ __ ] need that they're
getting it
nice that's heavy stuff i mean so are
you
i ate 45 crab cakes and called it at
night
[Laughter]
i do love a good way people [ __ ] on well
i gotta go to a wedding but i love it i
love getting hammered in a tucker oh
when she was getting dressed up to get
drunk
i loved like even saying anything where
i'm like i put on a t-shirt and we go
get drunk together
you want to move to get laid single guy
at a wedding
get a couple pops in you dance with
grandma
that's big i'm talking a slow shimmy
with that old bag of bones
oh every gal there's slipping on her own
squirt
works every time that's good yeah this
broad's better
than nightcrawlers you know what i mean
they come jumping into the boat
oh yeah yeah
that's my little tip i ain't got nothing
on uh may all your prayers be answered
on the doorstep
with the uh you can try to be sensitive
yeah or you can get out of the dance
floor and close some ass
yeah yeah trying to find a soulmate i'm
trying to get my dick wet let's go
exactly and if all this fails you know
bag nana
i was feeling myself after that speech
in my brother's wedding and tried to
make a move on uh
one of my sister-in-law's friends and
dad yeah shot down
impenetrable [ __ ] good stuff all right
i got a couple more here uh oh oh we i
didn't know we were going oh yeah we're
just whatever man you guys are casual
yeah very good good good smooth with it
you know are your bills on autopay
uh i'm trying to get there yeah yeah
yeah
you do it like you like caulk or you go
online and pay con ed every month or
are you like that are you still doing
all this [ __ ] yourself or does the
business guy take care of doing it
you're doing it i'm doing it and i i
tried auto pay but i'm so bad with that
[ __ ] that i uh i [ __ ] it up and i get
a call over like when are you gonna pay
then it goes into
late fees collections yeah so i'm kind
of [ __ ] on that but i
i want to do auto pay i i know i just
can't bring myself to do it for some
reason i'm like i don't want you
touching my money i'll give it to you
when i feel you're ready for it it feels
taking it feels weird it does yeah
i've set it up in the past and then it
could last maybe like a month or two
and then i shut it down oh really in
panic mode because things are coming out
and i'll be calling the bank hey don't
let them take this out
all right stop the auto pay right yeah
they're like this [ __ ] loser
i know did you guys i remember getting
my first ticket in high school for
driving or parking or whatever
and my dad was like just pay it it's 25
just [ __ ] pay it right now and i was
like i got it dad get off my back your
[ __ ] grease ball
and then didn't pay it now it's at 50.
he's like
told ya just [ __ ] pay it yeah all
right i'll pay it i i didn't get around
to it you know meanwhile i'm just
getting you know blow every night
so then uh it went up to like 150 and i
finally paid it and it was quite a
lesson yeah
it stinks i have a i mean i have like a
[ __ ] glove box full of them at this
point really yeah
you got a month you got to take care of
it i know but i got jammed up they get
you i got
yeah i've gotten the boot i've gotten
what yeah you got a boot
yeah i got a boot oh you got a boot i
got a boot hole
the wave of panic when i came out and
saw my car
wow sweating on the inside cold sweats
freaking out no money
no way to handle it man this was also
yeah this was like zero
this was like zero dollars yeah this is
when we were like
you know this is like two years ago we
were like proper broke proper struggling
comedian
no more of a wake-up call than a boot
because you know other [ __ ] i'll get to
it and i'll i'll skirt the system the
boot is like
i gotta handle this you're gonna find
this right right here right now you need
to get on the phone
and deal with somebody exactly there's
something very emotional about like
there's my co somebody's not letting me
drive my car i can't
use my things physical now yeah this
ain't no email or a letter in the mail
or a phone call this is
this is me in my face in my ass and in
new york the clock's ticking because
they boot you up
and you know the next step is you're on
the [ __ ] list the [ __ ] sandman's
coming around
that's the worst thing about this city i
got mugged once and they took my wallet
so and my phone
so you're like all right now i gotta get
back home and get to my bank or whatever
but
getting home requires a cab or a metro
car car
or a cash or a car to get a metro card
and you got nothing
so you gotta find a way to get money to
get your money
there should be a gentleman's rule let
me let me get my license and my
a license and my metro card that's good
that's i think that's reasonable yeah
if you're at gun point would you like
having your mugger money like 20 bucks
to give them my god here you go yeah who
told us
i was like colin quinn thing uh alex
just told us too oh yeah yeah
keep some money in your pocket keep some
money i don't have a wallet
that's good because that's what i
wouldn't want to lose right you want to
take my credit card it's got a thousand
dollar limit have [ __ ] fun
sure you know what i mean my bank
there's nothing in there so good luck
yeah you got my sag after card go tell
everybody you're a bozo
leave my license in my [ __ ] metro
card that's where profiling goes wrong
they go hey look at this white guy full
head of hair he eats well
this guy's gonna be doing all right and
then you're like oh i got a boot on my
car
i got no money in the bank i got a
[ __ ] thousand dollar cap i got herpes
like good luck
somebody did steal my identity uh in
2011
to try they went to jail to try and
uh get a tax return and they filed in my
name they ended up owing like 600
[Laughter]
[Music]
like i owe money and i'm a sex offender
i got to go door to door wow that's
hilarious um
as far as coupley things can you see in
the future
what kind of couple you and you and your
wife are going to be would you guys
uh ah just hearing wife will you will
you be the couple that works out
together do you guys work out together
what are you kidding me
no i we laugh at those people that's
what's great about her is we watch those
videos and laugh and then we jerk off
anything his and hers no no joint bank
account
no thanks she already agreed to it
really
i know she's a great girl great girl
you're doing a prenup
she herp she brought it up my man
i know not too shabby i i was like i
never loved you more
wow which is so funny because women are
like a prenup i'm like oh so you want
the money like what the [ __ ]
who's the weirdo here yes yeah yeah yeah
damn
man that's awesome on her part what a
[ __ ] idea oh that's a great classy
lady
yeah does she have a little bit of coin
nah she's broke
you're lost no she's got a real job and
she's doing all right
but she just actually likes me which is
one of the
first of all wrapping your head around
someone liking you is insane yeah
yeah but then you're like uh i think
she's really in for the real right
reasons
well that's good too because like in her
she's around the scenario of like
he might be thinking this let me get out
in front of it that's a good healthy
thing to do like hey i don't want you to
be worried about this or
you put you in a weird position or give
you anxiety so like i'm fine with it
that's [ __ ] fantastic she gets listed
in the divorce
you co-hosted two seasons
that's funny yeah but any lady out there
for the two fans that you have that are
women
i'm sure like go preen up just cause
he's thinking it the whole time he's
gonna resent you forever because you're
not gonna sign one yeah
sign one put your money where your mouth
is you like this guy or not mm-hmm
i can just think of george you gotta
have a little bit of coin to be asking
for a prenup though it can't be just
some bozo asking for a prenup
yeah right yeah you gotta be able to
protect something i can't i can't pull
that off
where's feminism you know live your life
i thought you were empowering and all
that [ __ ] so prove it
but i think in some states prenups don't
mean any even if you have a pre-op i
think like california is still a 50-50
split
i think new york might be too stay at
l.a kid
we got to look into that totes
going to vermont i gotta get to texas
quick
oh [ __ ] um what about would you ever
have a painting done of the two of you
you ever walk into a couple's house and
they have a terrible painting that's it
yeah
hilaire i would do it as a goof she
would be i think it'd be funny bearskin
rug
naked yeah yeah double-sided dildo
something all right now we're talking
yeah for a dream something i can get
behind that would be fun we would do
that but no no
it's nothing sincere i mean that's and
crazy people do that i want to get two i
want to get one of me and him in like uh
suits like yeah
you know like in a bit like you go into
like a business or like this yeah yeah
the painting is in the sauce
staring off to the left right right ryan
foley and toby
that'll be fun foley ryan and toby
worst law firm no credit yeah
um let's see do you currently have
renters insurance
i don't think so yeah that seems like a
scam to me yeah i don't get insurance on
anything a rental car
i just got a moped and martha's vineyard
no insurance the guy's are you sure i'm
like no what am i i got them open i'm
not going to give you [ __ ] 20 bucks
yeah
yeah yeah didn't wear the helmet take
that dork
yeah i like how norman's like kind of
cheap but not really like
very cheap i think you're notoriously
frugal i guess i guess i'm frugal my
parents are frugal i'm a frugal family
but
i mean cheap would be like you you don't
buy a nice engagement ring you cheat
yeah you don't cheap out on stuff like
no no and dinners i blow big and uh
booze i go i go hard on what's the most
you ever dropped on a dinner
oh man yeah well i've been out with some
you know you know when you go out with
like eight guys in vegas and you're like
what have we done all these [ __ ]
shots what have we
done felt like you killed a hooker
you're like what did we do you come too
you're like what the [ __ ]
i know who got the swordfish you're like
why is the waiter being so nice
because he knows we're paying his
mortgage with this deal yeah yeah so
then you know there's like a
like an eighteen hundred dollar meal and
you gotta divvy it up so everybody's
paying 600 or whatever but that's
i guess that's not the end of the world
you and the lady though what's that well
you enjoy the
the finer thing like if you guys are
going out to dinner you're like let me
get a bottle of wine or
like are you like still being like i'm
not paying 44 dollars for a steak type
chicken breast and mashed potatoes i've
done it but i don't like doing it i
think the most i've spent with the lady
is probably like
350. okay what's up that's good i guess
all right all right norman you ready to
start sweating dude ah [ __ ]
if you earn significantly more than your
spouse before the marriage you can add a
provision that limits spousal support
later
keep in mind that all prenuptial clauses
are subject to a judge's review
so if your agreement isn't fair it seems
retaliatory the court can eliminate the
provision
ah i gotta get a male judge all right
holy [ __ ] don't think that's a judy man
you start signing up to joe brown now
watner guy
yeah by the way judge judy from brooklyn
highest paid
woman on tv bananas i know bananas money
i had a friend of her a fr i think i
already talked about this on the pod
uh a friend of mine grew up with her
grandson and every uh a
i think he got in in school he would get
ten thousand dollars
oh yeah i know i'm such a dirtbag i
would just get one and be like all right
i don't need to try so hard just trying
gym
get one freshman year and ride it out
right yeah for the next four
kid 10 grand that's an atv a big screen
and a playstation yeah you're good to go
i remember hearing that [ __ ] bothered
the [ __ ] out of me
oh yeah that's crazy you got to be plush
like come on give me eight
yeah come on lady i'd go to the teacher
but yo there's 2k in it for you
or give me three grand for a c let's go
right
let's take it easy that's all i got as
far as the relationship stuff
all right good question good questions i
love it sorry
i feel like i uh i should have answered
longer no no no no no no no we have we
have some other ones i i do
subscribe to any magazines or
periodicals no what am i crazy
too much commitment i don't read i would
get them
even the netflix when they were the mail
ones yeah i would
wouldn't even get to all of them yeah
like i'll get to it and then you then
i feel like i view it as like an
obligation yeah like you're giving me
responsibility every month i don't
need that i worked at blockbuster and i
you know i loved movies
i went to film school i was like this is
going to be the best job in the world
and you get all the free movies you want
although it's going to be like tarantino
taking 10 movies home and watching
slasher films alone and all that
i didn't watch [ __ ] yeah that's what it
is that job stunk i work at a west coast
what's that western west coast video it
was regional it was like
it was like a shitty blockbuster but
they had the uh the back room
oh at your disposal oh boy
those you watched those we watched you
didn't get around to the other ones oh
you could take those you could take
those
on the low with the right manager i told
you we caught this kid that i went to
high school with his mom worked there
and we caught her one time taking a
porno home it was called time for an ass
[ __ ] never i'll never forget it
i've had to have mentioned this on the
podcast time
for an ass [ __ ] i love it it's a back
to the future parody
get out of my ass money don't hit 88.
marty i'm coming
einstein look away
oh man hey mrs miller why are you taking
home shaving ravens riots
all right i couldn't get it out yeah i
remember there was a seinfeld one back
there
yeah it's called heinfeld oh dude it was
that's not even good
oh dude it was so funny they had like
the guys like framingham
and like jerry peeking through oh dude
it was awesome oh
man that's hot the porn parodies are hot
to me they don't do that anymore really
all right the internet's got them yeah
yeah yeah they got like a family guy
and seinfeld family yeah it's animated
pull it up it's just lois getting railed
by brian
she's she's got a tight body on her
lowest oh yeah she got the very maternal
uh
figure to her sure sure why you looking
at me dude i don't know
pull it up d-bone maternal figure
it's just it's just got hurt she's curvy
curvy man what am i on trial here what
the [ __ ]
maternal figure what the [ __ ]
you like a milf thing i
[Laughter]
i think i even might have said it on
your last episode a kid
uh owned a kid owned a chain of uh
movie rental stores and when they went
under when like blockbuster moved and
they sold all the videos
and his dad kept all the porn from like
three locations in the basement
all the vhs yeah yeah that's a big stag
oh dude it was great gazong is the
artist
the first one we took yeah because that
made his way around the group
real quick were they colored yeah they
were vhs
but were they sometimes they were orange
or blue or you saw they were a lot of
those
yeah it was like it was over yeah and
then you knew something was out there
yeah you did something
that ain't plain strange in autumn i'll
tell you that
yeah those are the ones you had to
rewind yourself because they've been
spooled so many times it came off the
rim
that's one thing that we we used to talk
about growing up did you have the
individual vhs
rewinder i did my friend had and i i was
jealous
oh dude oh man that thing was fantastic
i know remember remember recording [ __ ]
off tv and you had to
just get down two of them yeah that was
fun it was like turning two keys for a
torpedo we never had
yeah i never understood that people's
parents would do that i mean what do you
work for the cia
what do you do that's insane to me like
bill gates how do you know about that
i remember the first time i saw a kid
with a cd burner he showed up with music
on a blank cd
and was like put this in and i'm like
where did you
get this what's sorcery yeah he's like
oh my dad took me everything like
your dad taught you how to burn c who
the [ __ ] is your dad i know right my dad
is
still still to this day probably doesn't
know what a cd player is
like his dad was burning him in like 92.
there's comics out there still doing the
dvd sales after shows i'm like
wow you're still going huh do you think
people buy them
i think they watch the dvd they buy them
as they look at just a tip
i feel bad for you like my shirt but i
sell shirts on there i don't think
anybody's wearing that thing
yeah they jizz in it once they clean the
gutters you know yeah they're wearing
what
have you ever sold any shitty merch
where you were like what like back in
the day
where you're like i'm trying to get this
cooking i made a coup beer coozies
i'll be coming back for ayg in the fall
don't worry yeah yeah
we're going to do some ayg ones they're
cheap and they can put
yeah that's 100 in your suitcase
not the ones that we're getting they're
very expensive which is why the price is
so high
top quality merchandise so that's what
we're all about yeah damn lighting and
cheap fabric
that's how you move merchandise nice
pull nice pull harry altman right wasn't
that who the guy was
oh yeah i worked for harry altman and
the 22nd street i sold raincoats for 20
years
[Laughter]
the executive yeah the first belt i got
yeah he catches himself in the mirror
that's the best
i went to take my belt off of the scan i
caught myself in the mirror to hit jerry
george yeah oh you gotta love it i love
it
good show um all right so sorry just
sold it to uh took it off of hulu sold
it to netflix that guy
has made more money with the same [ __ ]
than anybody on the planet it's crazy
because i was i got hulu for seinfeld
yeah obviously like the 599 level or the
4.99 like just whatever the basic
packages and then like two weeks ago i
went to watch it it was like you have to
upgrade to 64.99
64. well in order i guess it was the
last nuts the last couple of weeks
uh the last couple weeks it was on there
they bumped it up that i guess there's
like a price gouge to be like
anybody that will sign up let's [ __ ]
sure take their money for the next
couple of weeks how much did he sell to
netflix for
i'm sure hundreds of millions i mean you
sold
hulu how many years ago for 150 million
i thought that was forever
i thought so too jesus christ yeah
probably six years or something so that
means
he got the nbc money then he got the
syndication money when it goes to tbs oh
that
was like that's like that that ended up
being like billions billions
and then it's hulu now netflix and then
he what has he done two specials where
he does his old material
yeah so that's uh 40 million right i
mean it's just bananas
the same stuff is making more money
repackaging it
as a business manager he's probably got
a business manager i don't think he's
selling koozies on the road
no no i wonder what he does he how does
he feel about the merch
do you think he was like no but even for
like a
straw like a guy who's going on the road
he's like i gotta do it yeah he probably
gets that
he gets it he he's still got like a
that's why he sells so much [ __ ] because
he still has that
mentality much like us he's a long
island trash you know he likes baseball
and cars
that's true but uh dana gould had a
great point he said uh
they go do you sell merch he goes nah i
can't sell merch because i heard george
carlin
once say uh oh he goes i never saw
george carlin make change
and he's like that was my hero yeah if
he doesn't do it i'm not gonna do it
yeah but carlin was
you know a legend yeah
yeah yeah yeah i don't think it was in
the works when he was [ __ ] because
his black jeans and a black black
sweater yeah exactly in a weird ponytail
yeah a long rant
i just found the number for that ethics
played for seinfeld
right now let's do it over let's do a
guess okay i'm saying 250 million
okay fully 300 i'll say 100.
500. oh shut the [ __ ] up
shut up get a prop act over here what
wow
500 half a billy dude
i am correct me good show correct me if
i'm wrong
it's not that good you're not it's it's
worth every penny yeah
i paid 64.99 to watch an episode uh
i can't even really watch the the when i
if i'm going through it
like over like a course of time i'll
start it like season three and i'll go
through
when i get to like the early episodes of
season nine
i get like depressed well larry's gone
yeah they don't get a little
no i get just depressed because i know
it's a oh i only have a few episodes
oh i see i see there's a couple of good
ones on it yeah it was fun it was
it got a little cartoony but yeah it was
fun still a good show but uh
the early ones are really tough
sometimes they're really early early
yeah pilot just doesn't click for
something like there's certain things
we're like what the hell is this the
only reason it
popped was because it was cheers and
then wings and cheers was the biggest
show on tv
wings got good play because it was after
cheers you know wings was like a
half-ass
whatever show that nobody watched but
once wings got kicked
they put seinfeld there and then people
caught it yeah so that's just that
you know weird progression of it
happening happenstance
got them on and they started finding
their footing but what show gets three
years to find their footing now yeah
nothing well they said they were they
did really well with the high level
advertisers
[Applause]
i don't know if that's this week but
maybe next week
[Laughter]
antics now we're a lucy company around
here
that was before we started recording oh
yeah that's right it was
um what do you got right let's see we
have uh
so these are the patreon questions when
you sign up for patreon we'll ask your
questions
on the air uh with a guest or for the
family episode
this one a good porn segway uh this is
from maddie mcbee
you ever walk in on your pops whacking
it jesus wow
you gotta lose respect for your if your
dad's jerking off you said your old man
has a hog on you
really dude she's got a piano leg i mean
it's bananas yeah
and maybe i was little so it you know
yeah it looked bigger you know
like a what do they say things may
appear larger than the review mirror
yeah
yeah so uh he had huge swinging balls
too
just wow big bag bag of potatoes over
there but
uh i think that's perception i had the
same thing to i was just
like that's the thing that looks like a
[ __ ] bean bag yeah and you really
caught a look at this thing
oh i could draw it
but uh i wonder too if women see dicks
as bigger because they don't have one
so they're just seeing it i really
really got my fingers crossed on that
yeah and they don't really watch a lot
of porn ladies so i think
your dick is one of the few dicks aside
from the guy on the train
is the one they're seeing i don't know i
think maybe now
that's that's that's a good point yeah
we're in a tough spot those days
they're talking about like big dick
energy and stuff like that i ain't got
it
no no no there's there's a lot of vision
there's a lot of comparisons out there i
think
yeah more women are watching porn and
stuff like that yeah i'm in a tight spot
i'm not gonna lie
i think this is just your way of telling
us your girlfriend watches porn
she does not she's a classy lady
but uh yeah so uh never caught him
jerking it but
i've caught him plowing mom a few times
wow
yeah what's the oldest age was that like
were you 16 or was it like an eight type
thing
uh a little of both like uh well
probably when i was
when i was little i would wet the bed
and every now and then my bed was so
soaked i couldn't sleep on it so i had
to go sleep with them
you know i was probably like 31. their
bed was wet too
but i would go sleep with them and i
went to go sleep with them one night i
got my
my teddy bear and my jammy or what do
you call the the blanket
and i walk in and my dad is on top
really wow
really uh jackhammering and my mom's
doing some moaning and i was like
did i remember thinking should i stop
this because it looks bad yeah like it
looks
painful and she's kind of unhappy it
sounded like
but i just was like ah something in me
made me turn around
lights on or lights off off so it just
was figures
tv on no no did i chose playing
no no that would scar me with it tonight
holy [ __ ] you were there that long i've
i've cracked the door and like
barely yeah yeah i didn't get a [ __ ]
the the free show you got
no no it would be charging for that
mattress on the floor
dilapidated mansion you know light on
the
like hanging mechanics like back in the
day
yeah so it was still a massage bed yeah
young parent [ __ ] wait that was their
bedroom the mattresses
yeah i'll tell you we grew up in squalor
it was a weird home
holy [ __ ] yeah i [ __ ] didn't know huh
damn fucking's free
[Laughter]
but yeah that's crazy man that was i
don't know five years old and i guess i
saw him probably again
ten years later uh at a in the middle of
the day
wow yeah afternoon delight yeah that was
bags the light was you know the light
was on
it was still daytime and so the room was
fully illuminated
yeah so i saw it too much and i now is
there a convo everywhere
no wait you so they didn't know you
didn't they didn't stop
the second time i went okay guys one of
those
holy [ __ ] yeah all right
this guy's twisted your parents are in
town right now i know i wonder what
they're doing
i just caught them [ __ ] norman i'm
sorry man
no it's fine it's better to know they're
in love you ever see your people that's
one good thing your parents
uh together yeah oh separated but
remarried
for like 20 years at this point wait
they got no they separated in my
yeah yeah that's the ultimate trash move
yeah divorce thing
but then the second second wedding get
married again right garbage
trash what is that with the uh like
you ever you've seen your parents go out
and like fight yeah that that hurts as a
kid
i mean that's why i'm a comedian i would
say i would say so yeah that's heavy
yeah you're the clown i'm like hey all
right everybody relax nobody yell at
each other
yeah you know put the frying pans down
right and the knife i remember i heard
chappelle once say uh
as a kid in a weird home you're the ice
breaker and
and the comedian is the ice man it's so
true i was the youngest just kind of
like
hey everybody we're living in a weird
situation you guys hate each other my
brother's gay
let's hang out let's [ __ ] around let's
do juggling or something did they fight
i caught him a few times really just ah
i should have left hate and all that
[ __ ] then
they're still banging this sexual
attraction there that that just sure
that is great maybe you mean passion you
know it's a fine line
fighting and [ __ ] there's nothing
wrong with it
no no no uh i remember hearing my dad
and my stepmom going ah
i was upstairs they were going at it i
just turned the volume up on the tv i
was probably watching aside but i'm like
well this is going to bother me later
wow like fighting you mean yeah just
screaming like you
know and i'm like oh boy this is
i haven't watched coached in a decade
that was a good shower
t nelson nothing wrong with it no he's a
dilf
i had that show in the background my
whole childhood i never actually watched
it it would just be on the background
yeah that was weird it's like that i
talked about but i felt like it was on
forever
i know it was any it's it's not in
syndication anywhere
there's so many shows from the 80s and
90s that had like serious runs like four
five six
seven years yeah that were like staples
yeah and then
nowhere nowhere nowhere will and grace
will engrave they brought that back
yeah that's a bad example by the way
you've heard nor mcdonald's got the
greatest point
he's like this show is supposed to be so
progressive and like open-minded but
will would come and be like i had sex
with a man the crowd's like
oh my god they're laughing at you for
[ __ ] yeah
this is progressive yeah it's crazy it
was a different time it was that was
what 90s
yeah late 90s that were messing wrong
with it
not a fan it's got the boy body
yeah great
along came paulie pauly polly paulie
paulie holly paulie what wait that's a
soprano
yeah along came paulie polly
polly polly want a cracker sounds weird
[Laughter]
fully wants a turkey
um all right let's do a couple more then
we got a skedaddle here um
this is from jack everywhere a neck
pillow anywhere other than a plane
ah yeah i tried to write a bit about
this really yeah i mean
why why is it just for the plane it
doesn't make sense
bring it to the dmv bring it to a movie
bring it to a movie i get
no a train or a bus or why is that
though
why does it have to be transparent i
don't disagree with this it's a neck but
it's comfort
where are you going to lean it on you're
like it props up a little you know
huh hey do you take one on a plane do
you travel i do
i do yeah i and this here's trash i
found it at the airport
10 years ago it had you know jerry curl
juice and gray hairs on it a couple of
ticks and lice i flick those puppies
right off you still have the same i have
the same one
that thing's falling on the floor it's
got ebola it went through
wuhan and i still use it two times kid's
cheating
dude that's yeah that's cheap i can't
frugal that's cheap you can't buy one
they're like
the 9.99 real one ari says he steals
them
or whatever and then you just walk right
in he's gonna question it yeah get him
into more serious crimes here
hey listen he chose this life not me
yeah the life joe's making he's a
soldier yeah you know what's really i
think it's insane but you see with the
one that like blows up and you sleep but
like
you lay down and you've seen that yeah
that's a bit much
i think that's crazy because him on the
plane was doing that he was sleeping on
his on his
on his tray table that's not that's a
bad look yeah that's detention sleeping
yeah
yeah that's how you sleep in class i was
next to foley and have a lot of room to
work
you got to go forward he's taking all
the back room yeah yeah
i get that um are you a delta comp do
you like delta comfort i don't
foot rest yeah they're supposed to have
a foot rest like where you got an
ottoman
i've never heard of a foot rest on a
plane right i thought that's what that's
what she said but she the bar the ria
maria
that might be for like longer flights or
so i don't know foot rest
it didn't seem much different than a
regular they're bigger there's a little
bit more space
yeah seats are better a little more leg
room but here's the clinker back before
uh
the pandem delta comfort you got all the
snacks and the goodies and the booze
now that's over yeah because they're not
doing that [ __ ] now with the
with the coven so it is not as good
you still get a little more arm room and
leg room but not with fully next to you
oh yeah all right that's twice god damn
it
well nine iron huh you're fired
i paid for the whole seat what the [ __ ]
man he's got a point
excuse me what'd you say excuse me miss
i paid for my whole seat please
how come he gets two seat belts what the
[ __ ] i do have two seat pumps
yeah that's the one thing i've been
stealing stealing seatbelt extenders oh
so i have them from each different kind
of area it looks like a fighter jet dude
he's got him coming down the front even
they caught you to be like let him have
it yeah
he needs it and i have a great system i
don't wait till i sit down i ask right
when i get on the plane
because if you say because if you ask
when you're at your seat they tell
another flight attendant
and then all of a sudden some dude's
walking around going who needs to see
that extender
and they know i'm right here you can
take a look
good point yeah open your eyes i'm i'm
sweating here
yeah the guy dripping out of his comfort
zone
[Music]
oh man all right this one's from paul
ever use something that wasn't a
toothpick as a toothpick oh of course
what do you have a go-to i like a
business card very good matchbook is
nice too
oh yeah anybody with that good corner
yeah my dad was he would just keep
ripping it and just [ __ ]
yeah his teeth it's a good feeling one
time in class i got yelled up on my
teeth i used the uh the compass
it's got that needle yeah really get it
i look like a tough guy
here you go nerd take that back and use
it yeah picking your teeth with a
protractor
protractor there it is
all right is that what it is which one's
the that's the protractor okay the
compass has like the spike in the circle
that is insane if that was given to
children like
yeah every kid had one i mean you could
kill a guy i didn't know what they were
for i never made it to make a circle
yeah nobody did it no no no that seemed
like something from the 50s to me yeah
you know
it just never made sense all that [ __ ]
just that that [ __ ] paper cutter
clean off somebody in like the 90s had
the bit of like we have like the plastic
scissors
yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] decapitator
in the back yeah it's
yeah yeah now i have a nose bleed right
right yeah yeah he's good
did you guys have uh bunsen burners i've
always seen those in movies i never
never had that we had that we had the
big science tables that had a gas line
going into it
yeah yeah just the yeah we had it's
always colder in there
it was those tails you always wanted to
fall asleep when you got to science
class did you take a uh
pig apart no a pig yeah we did yeah yeah
we did the pig the baby baby yeah a pig
we did a frog like normal people we did
a frog too
why you did a frog in a pig we did a
baby once
got it right out of uh susie she was
pregnant was that a clinic but
yeah you did a pig a baby pig
everybody had one yeah everybody little
little anchor what
what it comes in like a vacuum sealed
bag you open it up and it's all bloody
it's got hair on it
looks like babe big like fresh direct in
the city yeah that's gotta be expensive
every kid gets a baby pig this is public
school for me i think what's a what's a
baby pig
toby a couple of bucks look it up give
it a go what's a baby it's a baby pig to
dissect
oh i say if you're buying in bulk
they're buying in bulk
they're not paying retail no wait you
want prices
yeah yeah they're government issued you
know this is for schools yeah sort of
school you're getting at a bottom line
pricing
right this ain't no uh retails for billy
they kill baby pigs just so [ __ ]
idiots in science class can take them
apart which they're not gonna become
scientists anyway
dude this picture is so [ __ ] up yeah
welcome to my childhood
yeah imagine eating lunch after that
yeah right baby pigs and huge hogs
[ __ ] swinging
oh right uh all right 33.95
not too bad for once a lot that's
not that's a lot check the 80s or the
early 90s at least they had to be a
couple of bucks
this is this is at home though this is a
single pig you're not buying them that's
why
we were getting them by the palette back
in the day oh 700 bucks a class if
you've got 20 kids in the studio
no no that's what's that is that math
what is that
where'd you get that all right if you go
to carolina.com you can get them
uh two for 25. now we're talking see
this
yeah there we go that's a heifer wow
those pictures are so brutal too they're
not good
yeah yeah it's uh try fingering a girl
after that by the way
don't use the line i hate the second
pick i'm in today all right
that's it there we go ladies and
gentlemen back again mr mark norman
buddy you got anything coming up that
you want the folks to know when's this
come out
uh i'm talking about you all right
it comes out uh next monday all right
come to houston baby i mean uh philly
philly
yeah yeah big philly i got a big feeling
go check him out helium helium bill we
sold out uh much
most of it but we're adding shows so uh
let's pack it in baby best in the biz
guys go
go check normand out new hour one of my
favorite clubs i'm all over the road
marknowmancomedy.com check me out i'm
coming to your town
fantastic buddy we love you
congratulations again thank you guys
thank you for coming in
thank you what do you got for him as
always you know rate review subscribe
everywhere youtube patreon at kevin ryan
comedy on social media then check out
the ru garbage page get us up over 10k
at ru garbage on instagram and come see
us in uh providence
on august 11th and laugh boston on
august 12th that's going to sell out
quick those there's
not a lot of tickets left for that guys
more dates coming up we're going to be
cruising and bruising all over this
country all through the fall and winter
we couldn't be more excited we love you
and we'll see you next time peace